these fishermen are throwing their nets
into mida creek lagoon for the fifth
time
one of them katana gonna has a wife and
26 children to feed
we used to go out and catch 60 to 70
kilograms of fish i earned enough to
support my family for three or four days
by selling them
but now i go fishing all day
and i catch barely three or four kilos
and sometimes i catch nothing
other fishermen have caught the juvenile
fish in the lagoon with mosquito nets
and high tide no longer brings enough
other fish to feed a family today
there's just one fish in the net
and it is poisonous
in the open sea in front of meter creek
a coral reef protects the lagoon from
the breaking waves
these two men work for an international
environmental organization a russia
they're researching fish stocks and the
growth of the corals
the two habitats are completely
intertwined there's fish that are
spending time as juveniles in the creek
and then maybe coming out to the reef as
adults and i'm sure the species that
even feed at different times maybe on
the reef and then in the creek so both
habitats are completely interconnected
and if one of the habitats was lost the
other one would become degraded
the marine researchers have been
collecting data for a few months now to
find out how great the damage to the
reef already is
most coastal residents have little idea
of how much the reef and lagoon depend
on each other
so the organization is also teaching
children from neighboring villages about
environmental protection we have the
coral reef
and the corals stanley bayer explains
the interplay within this ecosystem
so there is a balance here every part
depends on the other the mangroves are
protected from being eroded by the coral
reef here
then the mangroves also protect the
coral reef because sand that would come
from the land
being washed away by rain does not reach
the corals because the mangrove roots
holds it traps it
so it doesn't damage the coral in the
end there
you know that
at low tide there are sponges starfish
and crabs to discover and touch
that way the children learn to protect
their resources
we target the parents of the students
that is the adults the fishermen the
farmers with environmental education but
we also focus on the students so that we
build sustainability for the future they
will grow knowing how important this
this ecosystem is
in the afternoon the tide comes in and
with it water fish mussels and crabs
flow into the lagoon
thousands of birds migrating from the
north spend the winter in mida creek
where they find the best food
david
has been observing the fauna in the
lagoon and mangrove forest behind it for
more than 30 years
for arasha he guides tourists through
the nature reserve
they bring in the money he needs for
himself and for the environment
there's been a very big change
many people are
encouraged
to distract the forest
to distract the
mangrove trees
to earn
some money to help them
their
families
but still we
are really educating them to stop
behind meter creek lies arabuco sokoku
national park
david angala is on the lookout for rare
animals today he's been following the
call of the sukhokke scops owl
he only found it after two hours
the soccer scopes out
is endemic to sokkokke
and is well trained
by
distractions being done by the community
many animals threatened with extinction
live in the forest among them dwarf
antelopes
and various species of shrew
during the past few years david angala
has seen them less and less
nineteen-year-old kahindi gonna the
fisherman's son goes to secondary school
he's one of 130 pupils from the lagoon
whose education is being paid for by a
russia
being sponsored
was a very good
thing to me because
my parents my parents were not able to
produce the school fees
that's why
i felt happy
the authentic setting
kahindi plans to take his final exams in
three years
most of these students don't want to
hunt or fish for a living
like him they want to go to university
in the evening the gona family members
meet in front of their hearts
kahindi tells them about the history
paper he wrote in school today
his father talks about the lack of fish
i would like to be a teacher
to proceed with the education of my
brothers and sisters
so that they can also be educated
there's no fish for supper tonight
they hope the catch in mida creek will
be better tomorrow